حسنًا ،
الجميع مرعوبون من العنف
بغض النظر عن الجانب الذي أنت فيه ، إنه أمر
مروع ، لكن
هذا مجرد تذكير بمدى
الكراهية على كلا الجانبين
أحيانًا ومن الصعب عدم الشعور
بالمسؤولية أحيانًا عن جزء منه
أم  الطريقة التي
نتصرف بها كدولة تحرض أحيانًا على الكثير
من الكراهية على الجانب الآخر ولا يمكنني أن أعرف
أنني لا أستطيع أن ألومهم على الرغم من أنني
لا أعتقد أن العنف هو الحل
أم أننا نشعر أحيانًا أنه لا
مفر منه  سيشعر الناس بالضيق
ويتصرفون بطرق معينة لأنه ربما
ليس لديهم خيارات أخرى ،
وأنا أعتقد أن هذا ما
يؤمنون به وهذا هو السبب في أنهم يتصرفون بالطريقة
التي يفعلون بها ، فمن المروع أن يفقد الأشخاص
من كلا الجانبين
حياتهم بسبب هذا  لكن أه
أنت تعلم أنني أشعر بمسؤولية كبيرة تجاه
بلادنا ، الأشياء التي نقوم بها في
حكومتنا ، لا يمكنني اتخاذ
القرارات ولكن آمل أن أكون مسؤولاً
أجنبيًا